[Music]
at the start of your talk you both
mentioned crying I'm quite interested in
your views on the synthetic analytic
distinction which as far as I'm crying
to became most meaningful and I have to
say I do think there is a world and I
think both synthetic and others
compositions exist in the same world so
I tend to go a bit more to quite but I'm
assuming you perhaps think there is a
significant distinction how specific now
what were you saying which your own view
what my own view is as far as I
understand the difference between an
analytic statement which is true by
definition synthetic statement where you
have to go to the world of finance and
stuff
I'm just saying both those statements
exist in the world the whole concept of
the word since the concepts of analytic
and synthetic exists so why is it that
people said that cries got this wrong
there is a difference we need to
understand the difference between things
which are true by definition and things
which we have to go and discover
empirical Wow I mean you know there are
simple examples you know the coin
imprint seemed to reject these simple
examples at least when I had a seminar
with him my last year as an
undergraduate he said oh yeah some of
these statements you know that every
vixen is a fox or whatever writer nope
no bachelors are married are analytic
and there's little question about it and
what he really worried about was whether
some basic physical laws like he said
this the conservation of energy analytic
or synthetic I don't know right now I
suppose he had vaguely in mind that to
preserve conservation of energy than you
sorts of energy like potential energy or
so on are invented right
nevertheless I would not myself think it
was meant to be analytic but some sort
of physical principle that you know
people maybe didn't believe even at
certain times and might not believe at a
later time aren't so I myself would not
think that that was an example where we
don't know but you know yeah so my view
is that Quinn's conclusion was right but
his arguments for it weren't much good
and I think that I mean the that these
truths by definition I mean they're
supposed to be ones where as we're
roughly speaking if you're just
competent in the language then then
you're bound to agree to it and I just
don't think that there are any cases of
that so I mean you know something that
that probably people would would regard
as an analytic truth if they if they go
in for that distinction we would be
something like everything is self
identical because it you know it seems I
mean so just as you might think
oh that's just true by the meaning of
identity or something like that but I
I've come across philosophers who who
deny that being a self identical they
somehow I mean I think they're very
confused but but they're it's not it's
you know these are philosophers talking
in their native language who say oh well
when things are changing they're not
self identical awesome and you know and
I think it would be it would be kind of
missing the point if you told you know
that these these philosophers that they
you know they had to go back to school
to learn their own language I mean they
go by any normal standard they they do
understand the words and the grammar of
these things that they're they're saying
I mean they're just I think they're
actually making some logical errors but
but that you know if if even something
as trivial sounding is that can be
denied by people
do actually understand what they're
saying I don't I don't really think
there's room for anything which is
somehow just as were troupe purely by
definition and nothing nothing else I
mean you know I think Quinn's I thought
that if you granted the idea of
definition then these things that were
true by definition they would reduce to
logical truths but I don't I don't think
that even logical truths are somehow
just true simply by meaning and not and
not because they say anything I think
your logical truths say something like
like other kinds of truths and what they
say is something if you know some logic
you can see to be correct
you know well I suppose you know even
coin in that paper he thought reducing
it to a truth of logic was the criterion
for but in some side remarks and maybe
referring to his own truth by convention
I actually think the last two pages of
that paper where he shows that we
couldn't think of logic as a set of
conventions it was among his best
philosophical work and even violated by
Klein himself in some of these other
writings I think we have somewhat
different views about to what the extent
to which logic can be revised yeah I I
do think we probably have different I've
read what you say about that and I don't
agree right oh and Tim is famous for a
very difficult to accept you about
vagueness which doesn't appear in some
of your writings right but that there
always is like um am i bald well there's
some sharp cutoff point only we don't
know what it is right
basically his arguments against that
really by showing that this alternative
position doesn't work this one doesn't
work or this one doesn't work so what
else can we do say right but it's hard
for me to to swallow the conclusion
anyway yes I think it probably is for
many people though his great abilities
for arguing have persuaded some people
this which Sorenson hold that view
before you right yeah yes that's right
yeah I think he is the founder idea but
I don't know how many people related his
I like the ability for better right I
think that it might have been this
ancient Stoics who were who were the
founders of the of that view they they
well they were I mean they were yeah
chrysippus maybe I mean it's of course
so little of his work survives that it's
hard to say but but I mean he was
fanatical about holding on to the
principle of by valence and every
proposition is either true or false
and and he definitely applied that to
the the paradoxes of vagueness so yeah I
think I think he may be a may have taken
this this view in ancient times but of
but it's hard to to establish that on
the basis of the few scraps of his work
that survived
for motivates tops and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at AI TV
you